going back to school
nickelodeon has forever changed the
definition of loud and we're not even
sorry about it
get ready to catch your favorite family
for an hour-long special that you
definitely don't want to miss
make sure to tune in to nickelodeon on
friday september 11th at 7
6 c for the loud house special school
school will have the louds getting into
all new mishaps including one that may
or may not get lincoln
sent to an entirely different country
but wait
there's even more to get excited about
in this video we'll be sharing some
exciting behind-the-scenes facts about
this hour-long special that'll take
lincoln
lori and the rest of the loud stories to
a whole new level
it's time to get even louder with the
louds
[Applause]
when we last saw the loud family they
were getting ready to make some big
changes all you need is something
sensible that will get you back and
forth from school
especially lori the oldest loud was
preparing for college and on the hunt
for her dream car
can you imagine pulling up to fairway
university in this
she might have had to settle for mr
grouse's hand-me-down but all her
troubles were
paid off when she finally got to load
the car for her next adventure
now it's time for the rest of the louds
to get schooled as well
but schooled isn't only epic because
it's a special it's actually the series
first hour-long
episode it's double the fun and if
you're a fan of link and his siblings
you probably already know that the loud
house special isn't something you'll
want to miss
yep life is pretty good it might be the
show's very first hour-long adventure
but they've had plenty of other half
hour specials in the past
really loud music tripped and the one
that started them all
11 louds a leaping when stuff goes into
mr grouse's yard
it never comes back how could we ever
forget lincoln trying to save his sled
from mr grouse's backyard or lana trying
to catch a reindeer
am i right my reindeer networked we
wouldn't be surprised if schooled became
the best hour-long episode in the
history of the loud house
schooled also shows fans the loud family
like they've never seen them before
your favorite family is getting ready
for some big changes and new adventures
while laurie heads off to become a
college freshman her younger siblings
also move on up
although lori isn't there to help her
with her first day of school outfit
ooh when did we put a mirror in the
living room that's not a mirror that's
me
now go take your dress back lenny heads
to the 12th grade and
luna and luanne are right behind her in
11th and 10th grade respectively
lincoln finally joins lin in middle
school and saying it's an adjustment for
him and his pals is
probably an understatement but we're
sure middle school will be just as
hilarious as his time in the fifth grade
oh no
this is it lucy is making her way to
fourth grade lola and lana are in second
and despite lisa's genius status she's
still only in first grade
what was that it's science you wouldn't
understand but don't worry we haven't
forgotten about the youngest loud
lily has also joined the hashtag school
life and is out of diapers and headed
off to preschool
which also means that lynn senior and
read aloud successfully potty trained
all 11 kids or so they think
this could be the start of a bright
future
in case you missed it before lori heads
off to college in this hour-long special
fairway university to be exact if you
remember she managed to score herself a
scholarship to the prestigious school
with her a plus golfing skills i'm
officially offering you a spot on
fairways golf team
but this school takes golf college to a
whole other level
each floor in her college dorm happens
to be golf themed and really ties the
whole concept together
you could say that the show managed a
hole in one when it came to choosing the
decor of fairways dorms
these aren't all the behind the scenes
facts that come with her journey to
college
fairway university is actually located
super close to great lake city
that's where another very big family you
may know called the casa grandes live
it's only a few miles outside the city
so i'll be close to bobby
not to mention it's where her longtime
boyfriend bobby santiago also moved in
with his family the casa grandes back in
season two
if everything you've heard about the
schooled special so far sounds as
amazing to you as it does to us
we have some more pretty epic news you
can tag along with lincoln for his all
new middle school mishaps and follow
lori and her golfing dreams to college
when you tune
in to nickelodeon on friday september
11th at 7
6c for the loud house hour-long special
schooled
with new original music for you to dance
along to and hilarious jokes that'll
have you
laughing until you cry we can't imagine
spending our friday evening doing
anything else
we're so ready to get schooled and of
course this special wouldn't be possible
without the humor the loud house and
nickelodeon have brought to our screens
for years
hey lincoln you like seafood sea food
in fact the jokes in this episode get
even more
we guess you can say relatable in school
link manages to land himself in a
situation that gets him transferred to a
middle school in canada
plenty of the episodes great white north
jokes and puns are actually based on the
real life experiences that the loud
house's crew members had while living in
canada
it's hard to believe that we can get
even better than the jokes in the past
episodes eh
yes you can these hilarious moments will
no doubt be grouped with some of the
series top chuckle-inducing scenes
like luanne's award-winning puns lynn
senior's hilarious dad jokes
are zucchini me like
are you kidding me but i said zucchini
me or just anytime lenny is being
well lenny this the loud house special
also includes some epic musical scenes
you can dance along to
it's not just any new music either the
new original tunes were written by the
loud house musical geniuses
doug rockwell and michelle lewis you
might have sung along with them in the
past when they lent their voices for the
loud house
really loud music episode one of the
songs being added to the show's musical
roster in school
follows right along with the great white
north theme and it's called
welcome to canada and it's even sung by
doug
it'll be joining the ranks alongside
some major head bangers like toilet jam
laurie to lenny and play it loud it's
probably majorly hard to choose
but what's your favorite loud family
musical number uh
man i think we can best answer it in
song
school doesn't just come with new music
it also comes with a lead solo for our
leading loud
link that's right this is the first time
lincoln will be taking
center stage with his very own song the
spotlight is
all on him in the schooled episode
although he's never had a solo song in
past episodes
i can't believe i'm not going to the
concert me
the master of convincing he did once
sing with his best friend clyde in the
episode
really loud music we're not gonna lie
watching them perform
best buds while playing the arcade game
will never get old
even if it was all in luna's head we do
have to admit though that luna taking
the stage and showing the crowd of
thousands her true self at the end of
really loud music
might just take the cake for the best
scene of that episode do you have a
favorite moment from the season 3
special
i prefer to see my classmates as
co-workers or occasionally test subjects
speaking of past specials the loud house
took a page out of their own book to
name this
episode they used their unique e d
exclamation point ending that you've
probably seen before
you can check it out in their season 2
halloween special tricked
where lincoln and clyde set out to have
the best halloween ever
yeah you're right we probably won't get
much this year
bye of course heading to a fancy
neighborhood and trading trick or treat
for full-size chocolate bars
they were truly living the dream that
night the naming game also snuck into
the special episode tripped
if you thought going on a vacation with
your family was hard we bet it was
nothing compared to this episode's
chaotic road trip to weeping willow
resort with the louds
but at this point can we really expect
anything but chaos from this 13-member
family i'm
so sorry mr loud but you missed your
check-in time and we gave away your
rooms
their antics are what make the show so
entertaining after all
luckily lincoln and the rest of his
family eventually made it to their lake
michigan getaway
today's the big day the grand opening of
my dad's restaurant
lynn's table we can't forget the loud
house's cooked episode
the opening of lynn loud seniors
restaurant lin's table
included everything but the teamwork
they really needed
and while in the beginning the
restaurant totally took a turn for the
worst
the louds put their heads together and
came out on top once again
and this time they had a successful
restaurant to show for it
i think it was fantastic
now schooled joins the club as the
fourth special to use the loud house
naming technique
if these behind the scenes facts have
shown us anything it's that we can
definitely expect some awesome the loud
house episodes airing this fall on
nickelodeon
do you agree all we know for sure is
that the loud family's hilarious antics
just keep on getting better
what was your favorite behind the scenes
fact from the skooled special
what have been your favorite storyline
so far let us know all your thoughts in
the comment section below
and don't forget to tune in to
nickelodeon friday night at 76 c for the
hour-long
school special show us how much you love
the loud house by giving this video a
thumbs up and hitting that subscribe
button
catch you on the flip side